das sind ganz besondere einblicke in das
rotlicht und rocker milieu und in die
jahrelange arbeit eines polizeispitzel
eines v manns miami jenny er packt aus
ich habe grundsätzlich eine neun
millimeter dabei gehabt
da hat sich damals die schießerei
ereignet v leute sind für uns in diesem
extrem wichtig ich habe sachen erlebt im
erotik möglich es ist natürlich ein sehr
abgeschlossener bereichen etablissements
clubs sowie zimmervermietung die hells
angels immer mehr als bei anderen
mischten damit gesperrt unwahrscheinlich
viel geld damit gemacht ist ein großes
elend häufig reden wir ja auch über sex
und ausnutzung von osteuropäischen
frauen mit diesem sprengstoff sollte
einen anschlag auf das rotlichtviertel
handys ruhig verübt werden hier wollte
man zuschlagen oder die eine seite
produziert hatte also sarah gegenüber
der nächste händels es ging tatsächlich
darum wirklich diesen klub hier in
deutschland zu etablieren dann hat auch
die gegenseite das nicht auf sich sitzen
lassen und zurückgeschlagen
auch das wirklich so weit gehen dass man
mit tatsächlich keller schickte und das
macht eigentlich deutlich dass das ein
pulverfass war ich kann bestätigen dass
von handgranaten bis panzerfäusten über
kalaschnikows alles da was man zu den
krieg braucht
[Musik]
ja und über genau diese spektakuläre
doku möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit dem v
mann jan sander alias maria mit johnny
und unserem chefreporter frank schneider
der zusammen mit christine wahl diesen
film gemacht hat guten tag an euch beide
ja dann vielleicht erst an sie die frage
sei 2012 waren sie als frau mal im
einsatz haben sich in der rockerszene
getarnt wie gut sie das ganze
ich bin damals auf das landeskriminalamt
nordrhein-westfalen zu gegangen ich
hatte bereits behördenkontakte und hatte
zu verschiedenen lkw's den kontakt seit
jahren als verbindungsmann und habe im
dezember 2011 mich für einen verdeckten
vor einsatz für das lka
nordrhein-westfalen im rocker milieu
oder in den arabischen clans
vorgeschlagen und wie kommt man damit
klar wenn man gar nicht über seine
arbeit sprechen kann das heißt sie
mussten ja doppelleben führen verdeckt
ermitteln sozusagen und können ja auch
nicht mit ihren freunden und ihrer
familie darüber sprechen vielleicht auch
aus angst wie geht man damit um
ja sie isolieren sich letzten endes
komplett von ihrem sozialen umfeld sie
haben keinerlei soziale kontakte meine
kontakte haben sich letzten endes auf
leute im alltag beschreibt beschränkt im
fitnessstudio oder vielleicht teilweise
auch nur mal einkaufen und sie werden
zum klassischen einzelgänger eben weil
sie der schweigepflicht unterliegen der
geheimhaltung unterliegen
und wenn sie 24 stunden die figur miga
nie spielen in der öffentlichkeit können
sie auch nicht dann privat hingehen und
familie freunden oder vielleicht sogar
der eigenen freundin erklären wer sie in
wirklichkeit sind weil das ist verboten
und das dürfen sie nicht und sie haben
sich genauso an vorschriften und
verordnungen
zu erhalten wie jeder andere auch und
vielleicht anfang die frage wie schwer
ist es denn dazu so jemand zu einem
fachmann der ein doppelleben führt
vertrauen aufzubauen
ja man muss dazu sagen wir haben uns ja
schon kennengelernt vor vielen jahren
und zwar zusammen an meiner tätigkeit
als das wort aber meinen recherchen eben
damals ein zusammenkommen
roland rockern diesen satow daran die
damals sich hier in duisburg
breitmachten und eben den hells angels
konkurrenz machen wollen und und in dem
zusammenhang wir uns kennengelernt und
deswegen konnten wir uns und da kann man
ja gleich auch noch was zu sagen er ist
er denn auch nach seiner tätigkeit
selber sechs jahre gefängnis gegangen
und nach seiner haftentlassung haben wir
uns wieder getroffen und er hat mir dann
erzählt das dahintersteht ich wusste
dass damals ja auch überhaupt nicht dass
er dieses doppelleben leben führt und
habe die sache natürlich nach
recherchiert was er mir erzählt hat dann
hat sich herausgestellt dass stimmt eben
alles so und er hat eben in hamburg für
cell klare arbeitet hier
nordrhein-westfalen eben auch als v-mann
und das interessanteste war sogar dass
eine hier gefahren ist oder aus
steuergeldern bezahlt wurde nämlich vom
land weil er die ja auch zumindest zähne
sich sozusagen zu etablieren und das war
natürlich spannende einblicke und
details die man sonst ja auch nicht
mitbekommen man kennt die fälle
man kennt die ganzen situation die er
dann beschreibt da wenn man nicht
plötzlich sie in anderen blickwinkel mit
und das war eigentlich das wirklich
spannende und auch ungewöhnliche an
diesen einblicken die wir jetzt bekommen
habe herstellen zwischen ihnen beiden
ein vertrauensverhältnis
ja ich würde schon sagen und gewisses
vertrauensverhältnis notwendig sein das
kann man ja das auch nicht so zusammen
machen er hat ja auch sich uns
anvertraut er geht ja auch damit ein
hohes risiko
die erste frage die ich mir natürlich
gestellt warum macht er das überhaupt
dagegen es nicht um geld oder was er
wollte einfach mehr oder weniger mit
seinem alten eben auch freuen und noch
einmal klarmachen
ich war eben nicht nur den wegweisern
ich habe eben auch sozusagen fürs gute
gekämpft ich habe ein doppelleben
geführt und das kann er vielleicht
selber auch noch mal am besten erklären
er wollte ja auch einen schlussstrich
ziehen und einmal für alle mal sagen mit
dem thema ist für mich vor weichen mit
dem milieu nichts mehr zu tun
jannik genau warum sind sie da so offen
warum geben ihre geschichte so offen ja
wieder frank stand sagte ich möchte mit
meiner vergangenheit aufräumen ich bin
seit mai
inhaftierung der rechtskräftigen
verurteilung natürlich nicht mehr
einsetzbar und habe letzten endes jetzt
auch für meine entwarnung gesorgt weil
ich der meinung bin dass ich gute
menschen in deutschland grundsätzlich
nicht zu verstecken haben ich habe meine
arbeit gemacht ich habe recht und
ordnung verteidigt ich habe dafür
gesorgt dass straftaten aufgeklärt
werden und auch verhindert werden
ich kann mich nur daran erinnern dass
ich in den 2009 13 jährige mädchen aus
bordellen befreit habe mit oder in
zusammenarbeit mit dem landeskriminalamt
hamburg und das sind für mich wichtige
dinge genauso wie wir
sprengstoffanschläge und mordanschläge
in duisburg damals im rotlichtviertel
verhindern konnten
mit der polizei duisburg zusammen und
dafür braucht man sich meiner meinung
nach in keinster weise zu schämen und
die paar kriminellen die wir hier in
diesem land haben
die sollten hier nicht die oberhand
bekommen heute sind ja kein fan mehr
erleben sie jetzt trotzdem ja
ungefährlich weil wer geht denn die
rockerszene auf ihren ausstieg und
generell auf dieses geständnis das sie
halt als v mann ermittelt haben
ich denke mal dass der opa bereich
besonders die rocker oder auch die
arabischen clans anderes zu tun haben
als einen ehemaligen v mann der polizei
zu verfolgen und eventuell dem irgendwas
anzutun ja fakt ist ich lebe hier immer
noch in einem rechtsstaat und ich bin
genauso in allen bereichen des
öffentlichen lebens anzutreffen in jeder
fußgängerzone in jedem urlaubsgebiet in
jedem einkaufsladen wie jeder andere
auch ich ziehe mir kann der sonnenbrille
auf ich verstecke mich nicht
oder oder
gehen nur noch nachts auf die straße wie
gesagt ich glaube an unseren rechtsstaat
und sollte es mal zu einer begegnung
kommen wird es mit sicherheit vielleicht
die eine oder andere diskussion geben
aber ich gehe da ganz einverstanden mit
um weil wie gesagt ich bin der gute in
der geschichte dankeschön miami jenny
und danke auch schön danke auch an frank
schneider für den film
und ja vielen dank für diesen
interessanten einblicke und die doku
können sie ab heute mit bild plus dann
hier schauen